Heidi's in Idaho my husband doesn't
think we need $1,000 emergency fund he
thinks that money should go towards
paying down our debt and if we have an
emergency fund then we can put it on the
credit card he ultimately thinks it's
the same thing therefore he is
indifferent yet we've had this
conversation multiple times I
desperately want to be on the same page
otherwise I know we will never be
debt-free how can I get through to him
well I'm not sure you can because he's
stupid I mean really you're sitting
there broke and telling me what your
financial plan is and arguing with mine
I mean that's dumb that's like a
500-pound man arguing with a personal
trainer about diet Oh like your plan
well I don't give a crap that's just
dumb seriously I mean I've done this
kind of dumb stuff I've argued with
people and I didn't know what I was
talking about because arguing is like a
sport in our family but but that's just
dumb
and I you know honestly I would go you
know it's kind of dr. Phil moment you
got a look at this oh boy go hey your
plan genius got us here so I don't think
we're going to use your plan how's that
working for you that's your dr. Phil
moment what's not working you don't even
have a thousand dollars and you're
arguing about how to handle money so
listen there's no shame in being broke
I've been there but being prideful and
acting like you're a dead gun money
expert when you're broke is kind of
ridiculous so how do you get through to
him I'm not sure a board I don't know
but I mean i-i've lost my patience with
some of this stuff seriously so I don't
know how you get through to him honey I
think you need to tell me look we've
been trying your weight for years we've
been trying my way for your son of it
work let's try something else
I mean here's the thing let's do it for
90 days
let's do exactly
what the Total Money Makeover book says
don't argue with it don't try to have a
freaking theory of your own submit
yourself to a plan try something for 90
days if you get out of debt and you have
a thousand dollars in the bank and you
don't like it you can spend the thousand
and get right back in debt I could be
wrong right you could go right back in
it is that simple you guys if I hire a
personal trainer and I won't do what he
says I'm stupid you know I mean why am I
going to pay this guy to sit here and
tell me what my nutrition needs are he's
in better shape than I'm in what my
exercise regime should be and then argue
with him like my theory is better
are you sure that applies to me you sure
I can't what maybe I can take in more
calories than I burn I'm sure I'll lose
weight that way you sure I'm not the one
exception to freaking physics on the
planet I mean really why do we as humans
do this I do it too but I mean it's just
dumb when I do it it's just dumb when
you do it it's just stupid and dumb I
mean really it's just dumb you hire a
coach to teach you how to play a certain
sport and say you know your swing is off
change this your your step is off change
this you you know your stutter stepping
in the pocket take three solid steps
gland flat on your feet [ __ ] your arm
and throw I mean you know do what the
coach says there's a reason you brought
him in submit yourself to the plan you
know you see these basketball coaches I
don't know any by basketball was
listening to it guys are talking this
morning about how he had a coach in
college that completely changed the
mechanics of his shot his basketball
shot and we changed the mechanics as
accuracy went way up his release was
quicker he's releasing at the top rather
than the bottom of the arc everything
about his shot was different and it
changed though it changes it made him a
pro versus a college player because he
li submitted himself to someone who knew
something more than he knew
and I said this stuff is that simple you
guys it really is so I don't know how
you get through time I don't know but
you know maybe you just how's it working
for you you're playing you know genius
you've been doing it this way for ten
years looking where you are we are
broken in credit card debt using your
best plan so maybe your best thinking
isn't going to get us there maybe we
need some new thinking maybe we need to
borrow someone else's brain for a while
that's what happens when you bring in a
coaching anything in your life whether
it's a personal trainer an athletic
endeavor you know I learned to barefoot
water skiing on 16 years old stepping
off a ski back in the day that's the way
we used to learn this ski learn to
barefoot get up on a slalom and step off
from 16 to 48 I barefoot skied exactly
the same way I never changed the thing I
never got any better
I actually got worse because I got older
and more out of shape right was it 16
anymore you know we hired a guy we have
the harder guy to come to our lake house
for the summer and train us the number
one barefoot waterskiing guy in the
world at that time Keith's an orange and
Keith spent a week with my son my
son-in-law me a buddy of mine another
guy and basically beat the snot out of
us for a week and every time we would do
one little tiny thing wrong he would
make sure we fell so we remembered the
lesson and he was not brutal he's very
kind he was an excellent teacher but
yeah now you know we people in our
family one foot backward I'm a backward
barefoot ER I get up you know I don't
get up on a ski anymore I get up with
proper ways you know I mean all in all
it was in one week I changed a lifetime
of that sport why because I submitted
myself to somebody who knew something I
didn't know
and I didn't go you know I don't know if
I agree with your particular theory on
this he's the best in the world he won
he left my house that year went to
Taiwan and won the world games okay he's
the best in the world I'm not going to
argue with this guy about how barefoot
water ski I mean that would have been
just stupid now I felt like arguing with
him at a time or two because I mean we
ate Tylenol sandwich for lunch every day
we were getting the crap beat out of us
it hurt but we were learning my learning
curve during that one week went through
the roof and consequently I'll probably
be able to barefoot you know well up
into my 70s or 80s because of the
technique because I learned how to
properly do certain things position body
muscle memory the process you use in a
physical activity and it's not any
different when you're dealing with
something a mental activity like
handling money or nutrition or your
marriage it's a habit is formed I mean
if you've been married three times don't
tell me you don't need pre-marriage
counseling because you got this figured
out you ain't got it figured out you
have not got it figured out you know
that you need to meet meet with a pro
you need a counselor or coach in your
area so you need different muscle memory
a different process that you plug into
that simple stuff it's that easy you
guys it is so I mean this idea that
where you're going to argue with a
proven plan is not a reflection on the
plan it's a reflection on you you're the
problem
submit yourself to a plan try try
something new for 90 days see what it
does cut up I'll get your credit cards
out right now every one of them not even
that one you hide in the back get them
all out right now cut them all up close
all your credit card accounts pay them
all off get a debit card you can do all
of that in the next hour
do something radical and different so
that you get something it's radical and
different you're not going to get
anything radical and different doing the
same old crap over and over and
discussing theory submit yourself to a
plan try something new something
radically new you get radically
different results
it's just not rocket science people but
it is about pride the negative kind of
pride it's in your way it's in my way
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]